as we are counting down to the big game
all week long that's right we've been
talking to Sasha Loftus she is live out
in Glendale once again this morning and
this is important for people who do want
to bet or are just interested in
watching the game the injured players
report Sasha
yes good morning John and Heather injury
reports very important a lot to talk
about here those are officially out for
both teams and hey it is another
beautiful day here in Glendale as they
get ready to practice again hit the
field and prepare for the big game now
as I mentioned both injury reports out
for both teams the biggest name on it
obviously Patrick Mahomes of the Chiefs
while he's still dealing with that high
ankle sprain head coach Andy Reed said
he can still do everything the team asks
of him at game speed that is dangerous
for Philly but a healthy team just as
dangerous all roster members for the
Eagles eligible to go offensive tackle
Elaine Johnson hasn't given up a sack
All Season his growing will need surgery
in the off season but for now he's
listed as Limited in practice he will
play on Sunday speaking of Lane he and
Mahomes more like than you might think
both preaching the fact that their teams
need to keep preparation the same not to
stray from what got them to the Super
Bowl in the first place
but yeah I mean it really is it's a it's
a physical game uh you know you're
playing against Elite intelligent
players that are smart at what they do
so uh you know game planning and and
practice and and all that stuff adds up
um you know the game's only three hours
of the process and you know you have a
lot more in between that so I think I
think you have a better understanding of
the whole process so you can kind of
find those little those little Windows
where you can get a little extra film
study in a little extra rest
now again both teams hit the field again
today but you heard Mahomes he was
talking a lot about that rest and how
important that is as well and as Heather
said a lot important for a lot of people
out there in southern Nevada getting
ready to place the bets on which team
those profits the over under so of
course we will be here all week tracking
it for you we're having a great time
we'll send it back to you
our